los mercados cerraron el día de hoy con
alzas esto se traduce según algunos
entendidos como el mejor día para las
bolsas estadounidenses desde el mes de
junio del presente año específicamente a
finales de ese mes cuando los mercados
estuvieron muy atentos al desarrollo de
la cumbre del g20 que se llevó a cabo en
la ciudad de osaka en japón el avance
mostrado por wall street' el día de hoy
ha sido el mejor si lo comparamos con
las jornadas electorales desde el año
2008 detalladamente el dow jones el
principal dentro de wall street registró
un alza de 2.06 por ciento hasta cerrar
en 27 1480 enteros así también
repuntaron el standard and poor's 500 y
el nasdaq compuesto con un incremento de
1.78 y 1.85 por ciento respectivamente
si lo comparamos con la jornada anterior
louis este efecto que usted nos dice se
quedó en los eeuu o se trasladó también
a otras bolsas en el mundo lo escuchamos
en efecto la perspectiva fue positiva y
se trasladó en un primer momento hacia
las bolsas de europa donde disminuyó la
preocupación por el impacto de este
segundo brote de kobe 19 en el
continente y la atención se centró en
todas las elecciones estadounidenses por
ejemplo el dax alemán registró un cierre
de 2.55 por ciento en la jornada para
cerrar en 12 mil 88 enteros un efecto
que también se vivió en la bolsa de
parís el cac-40 y el ibex-35 que tiene
que ver con la bolsa de madrid que
presentó un alza de 2.52 por ciento para
muchos su mejor avance desde el 11 de
agosto de acuerdo con los medios de ese
país por otro lado la bolsa de milán fue
la que mayor avance mostró a lo largo de
la jornada con tres puntos 19%
louis eso en cuanto a las bolsas
europeas pero que hay de américa latina-
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que
veníamos de un lunes festivo en la
mayoría de los países hoy se abre la
jornada
y con esta elección en eeuu en américa
latina' santiago con excepción del ipsa
de chile también se dieron resultados
positivos el liderado principalmente por
la bolsa de sao paulo bovespa por otro
lado las acciones argentinas que se
cotizan en wall street' marcaron un
cierre positivo y ello impulsó que el
índice merval el principal de la bolsa
de buenos aires tuviese un cierre de 47
mil 965 enteros como ya lo habíamos
adelantado el ipsa de chile cerró en
negativo durante la jornada de hoy pero
nada tiene que ver en este caso con las
elecciones en eeuu lo que sí influyó en
este caso es que mañana ese país
decidirá en la cámara de diputados una
nueva votación sobre el proyecto del
retiro del 10% de las administraciones
administradoras de fondos de pensiones
algo que tiene bajo la expectativa a
todos los inversores bueno louis y
finalmente que otro impacto ha generado
esta expectativa electoral que se da en
eeuu en el resto del mundo bueno además
del cierre positivo en los mercados el
precio de algunas materias primas
también se vieron impactadas
por ejemplo el petróleo de texas cerró
este martes con un alza de 2.3 por
ciento hasta los 37 puntos 66 dólares el
barril por su parte el precio del barril
de petróleo brent para entrega en enero
terminó este martes en el mercado de
futuros de londres en 39 puntos 68
dólares lo que quiere decir un alza de
1.85 por ciento respecto a la sesión
anterior
el oro se fortaleció en 0.6 por ciento a
1.097 punto 06 dólares la onza este es
el nivel más alto en la última semana ya
que algunos inversores optaron por
protegerse ante una posible extensión de
los resultados electorales más allá de
las próximas horas adicionalmente el
rendimiento de los bonos del tesoro a 10
años aumentó cuatro puntos básicos hasta
en 0.88 por ciento el más alto en los
últimos cinco meses y a 30 años subió
tres puntos básicos hasta el 1 punto 65
por ciento